[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: BigQuery is a fully
managed cloud data warehouse
that provides
incredibly fast SQL
analytics over large datasets.
You can write and run queries
directly in the BigQuery web
UI.
In this video,
you will learn how
to use the BigQuery
UI to run a query.
You will query the USA
Name Data public dataset
to determine the most common
names in the US between 1910
and 2013.
This same process can be used
to query other public datasets
available through the
program, your own datasets,
or any other dataset to which
you have the right permissions.
Get started by navigating to the
BigQuery UI at console.cloud.go
ogle.com/bigquery.
If you are new to
BigQuery, use the video
linked in the description
below to set up
a new project in the
BigQuery sandbox.
No credit card is required.
If you are already a BigQuery
or Google Cloud platform user,
you may select an
existing project.
You will then land in the Query
Editor, where you can write
and run SQL queries directly.
If the Query Editor is
not currently displayed,
click Compose New Query at
the top right of the window
to summon the editor.
Before writing a
query, you'll start
by navigating to the USA
Names public dataset.
In the Resources section
of the left hand nav,
click Add Data
and Pin a Project.
Type bigquery-public-data,
separated by dashes,
and click Pin.
This project contains
several public datasets.
Expand the project and scroll
down and expand the USA Names
dataset.
Click on the 1910
to Current table
where you can review
the table schema.
The schema outlines the
structure of the table
and provides a list of the
columns available to query.
Here, you can also view the
table details and preview
the data.
Click Query Table, and a
preloaded query statement
will appear in the
Query Editor, which
you can begin editing directly.
For this quick start,
instead of editing the query,
copy and paste the
query text provided
in the video description
below into the Query Editor,
and then click the
green checkmark
on the right hand
side of the window
to view the query validator.
A green checkmark
icon is displayed
if the query is valid.
If the query is invalid, a
red exclamation point icon
is displayed.
The validator also
shows the amount
of data the query will
process when you run it.
Now, click Run.
The Query Results page displays
below the query window.
At the top of the
Query Results page,
the time elapsed and the
data processed by the query
are displayed.
Below, you'll see a table
displaying the query results
with a header row containing
the name of each column you
selected in the query.
You may now choose to save the
query to be accessed and run
at a later time.
You may also save the
query results in one
of several formats
for further analysis,
or follow the direct link
to explore the results
in Data Studio.
Happy analyzing.
[MUSIC PLAYING]